and how how was it that uh you
eventually got
caught how did you eventually get into
trouble
um that took a long time so uh
dial so i come here in 1978 uh i uh make
my way into a profession i work at
midlife and uh so i'm in the
country for
uh
eight and a half years
when i made a mistake
i had a steady girlfriend
who
was a citizen of guyana
she
came here illegally
and at one one one day she
uh confessed to me that she wasn't a
little bit closer
well you can you can move it
well she confessed to me that she was in
the country illegally
and
and
she asked me if i could help her become
a citizen
and after some analysis i figured i
could do that
and it worked
so here's one illegal who made another
illegal eagle
um
and but then
the mistake was that
i wasn't aware that this was
it's very typical for
west indian ladies who want to move up
they kept they catch themselves
themselves a man and then get pregnant
she got pregnant
uh and uh
she gave birth to a girl
in
1987
in the month of may june 1st of june
and
that changed my life i wasn't not
prepared for that so but i'm seeing this
little girl grow up i watch her
uh
you know take her first steps
and and you know she had the biggest
eyes
and nice curls a very very pretty girl
and
i
i've always had a
a a great liking for pretty girls right
this was my daughter
and
without really being aware of it i fell
in love with her
at big time
it was uh
i think at that point there was a point
when when i became a human being
you know because i
up until that point i was very much of
an egomaniac even though i wanted to
help the world but it was really all
about me you know
i'm i'm the special guy
uh you know i i get to do things that
almost nobody else can
and i'm eventually going to
have decent money and have a good life
it was all about me
i mean i left my german wife
to spy in in the soviet union
i could have at that point could have
said when you know maybe i shouldn't
so
so i fall in love with this girl and she
was 18 months old when the
the kgb
was spooked uh somehow they got some
information through some channel that
indicated that i
i was in danger of being caught
and
they decided to
implement the emergency procedure
so there was a particular plan that we
had in case i had to run either i find
out myself that i'm in danger or they're
telling me
the procedure was as follows i had
emergency documents
a driver's license
may have been a secondary document of a
canadian
that i
buried
in a park in north of manhattan
someplace
i was supposed to
retrieve the documents
and make a beeline to
canada
going across
the uh i think it's called the french
bridge
at niagara falls
i had tested
their they asked me to test how easy it
was to cross and in those days you
didn't even have to show documents you
just walked
so and then make my way to
ottawa where i would
get in touch with a diplomat there kgb
agent and they would
extricate me out of canada
straightforward right wow
now that was so and i would have to set
a signal
telling them that i'm i'm i'm starting
the emergency procedure
we had two signal spots
uh one was for me to put a signal
there was some some place in manhattan
and it was under a bridge
and it was next to a highway when the
the
when
the the the soviets lived in the north
of manhattan and they would drive to
work
uh a certain road and they would pass by
that spot every day
so if i
i place a red dot
you know a paint red dot on that spot
that means they would be alerted that
i'm i'm on the run
the other
spot was for them to put signals there
and for me to read and that was on my
way to work
on a on a
on a support beam for the
a train that ran above ground
in that part of town and uh
one morning it was um
in december
i went to when i was going to work it
was still dark
so i go there and you know as usual i
just take a peek and not expecting
anything and there was this red dot
um
may i use the s word yeah oh yeah maybe
because the internet that is that is
what popped into my head oh [ __ ]
see at that point i was still trying to
figure out one day i need to go back
they will call me back how do i take
care of this girl
so that was what that red dot meant the
red dot means emergency you're out i'm
young
actually it it if you read this you just
don't go home
don't don't pack your bags just make a
beeline collect the
uh the documents and get out of there
wow yes
and you had documents buried in a park
yes
actually
after and that was then nine years later
when the fbi when i started working with
the fbi we went and i found the
documents that were still there
it wasn't really buried there was a a
park bench that was broken and you know
the the concrete
uh
things on both ends that that hold up
the board there was one of those
concrete elements that was still
standing there without anything so i
pulled it back and put the document
underneath and nine years later we're
still there wow
that helped with my credibility
for by with the fbi you know so you saw
this red dot yeah and i said oh [ __ ] and
because i wasn't ready to go i had not
found a way to take care of this girl
who i loved dearly
uh because her big yes
name is chelsea
uh she's 34 now yeah same year she was
born a month before me oh really yeah
so uh and uh and her mother
was poorly educated she had i think four
four years of formal education
chelsea would have
grown up in poverty no doubt in my mind
and i couldn't stand that thought
so
i just decided to ignore the dot
i told you
i was always a risk taker and there
obviously was a risk if they if if
the kgb was right
and i hang around for some some more
days
the fbi will come knock on the door and
i wound up in jail right
[Laughter]